este humilde casete es un pedazo de
historia musical en él hay una grabación
de una entrevista con john lennon y yoko
ono incluida una canción nunca publicada
ver y opis la grabación surgió en 1970
durante una entrevista con cuatro niños
para la revista de su escuela mientras
la famosa pareja estaba de visita en
dinamarca
entramos a la sala de estar y vimos a
john yoko y los demás sentados en el
sofá estiró las piernas sobre la mesa
con sus calcetines de lana fue
simplemente acogedor
los vinos anunciarían públicamente su
separación en abril de ese mismo año
aunque ya se habían disuelto
extraoficialmente varios meses antes de
la entrevista
durante media hora de grabación
lennon habló sobre su paso por el grupo
y su campaña por la paz con su compañera
el
resto de usted en work and i' de un
local y los cuatro estudiantes ahora en
sus 60 s decidieron vender el casete
para no tener que decidir cuál de sus
hijos lo heredaría